[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti io sono tito caffi
sono un ricercatore della facoltà di
agraria dell'università di piacenza e
vorrei condividere il lavoro che faccio
tutti i giorni quelli che sono i nostri
obiettivi di ricerca di insegnamento e
di approfondimento in particolare sulla
sostenibilità in agricoltura
noi affrontiamo lo studio della
sostenibilità con due obiettivi
principali ovvero da un lato quella di
misurare la sostenibilità noi cerchiamo
di individuare e mettere appunto
indicatori che ci consentano di
quantificare quelli che sono gli impatti
del processo agricolo in modo da avere
un'indicazione oggettiva appunto una
quantificazione e capire permetterci di
migliorare o aggiustare il tiro verso un
obiettivo in in un modo coerente e
quindi che possa essere riprodotto e
compreso facilmente sia dal punto di
vista della produzione che del
consumatore dall'altro lato l'obiettivo
è quello di mettere a punto strumenti
tecniche e integrare tutto questo in
strategie che permettano di migliorare
la difesa delle colture per esempio un
aspetto su cui molto abbiamo e stiamo
lavorando è l'utilizzo di microrganismi
ovvero di
agenti di biocontrollo quindi uno
strumento del tutto naturale che se
utilizzato al momento giusto e con un
approccio corretto permette di limitare
la diffusione o diciamo un particolare
stadio sviluppo di una malattia e quindi
ottenere dei risultati interessanti di
protezione delle piante
il mio lavoro è quello di partecipare
alla messa a punto di modelli
previsionali
si tratta di modelli matematici che in
base ai fattori ambientali simulano lo
sviluppo delle malattie su diverse
culture ovviamente specifiche malattie
per specifiche colture questo non è solo
un esercizio diciamo a livello di
ricerca ma permette di mettere a punto
degli strumenti che aiutano chi opera in
agricoltura a ddv individuare i momenti
salienti in cui intervenire perché a
volte è necessario intervenire noi ogni
anno perdiamo circa il 30 per cento
delle dei prodotti agricoli per l'azione
di patogeni insetti e malerbe quindi è
chiaro che noi dobbiamo migliorare
dobbiamo intervenire nel modo giusto al
momento giusto
e i modelli previsionali ci permettono
di fare questo avendo l'individuazione
del momento in cui è più efficace un
trattamento
noi possiamo fare quello smettere di
fare i trattamenti sbagliati al momento
sbagliato proteggere la coltura quindi
ottenere un risultato agronomico ma
anche economico per l'azienda agricola
che sta producendo quella quel bene
aumentare la sanità del ben del prodotto
agricolo e dell'ambiente perché
riduciamo quelli che sono gli impatti il
2020 nonostante tutto quello che è
successo è ancora l'anno internazionale
per la salute delle piante è uno dei
motti di questa anno internazionale
individuato e promosso dalla fao uno dei
moti di questa iniziativa è proteggiamo
le piante per proteggere la nostra
salute
questo è effettivamente una una grande
verità è un messaggio che mi sento di
condividere
noi dobbiamo proteggere le colture
agricole
e nostro compito non per un obiettivo
non solo per un obiettivo di produzione
della derrata agricola ma per un motivo
di qualità della dell'ata agricola per
un motivo di riduzione di di un
obiettivo di sostenibilità che permetta
di produrre bene rispettare l'ambiente e
migliorare il mondo in cui tutti noi
viviamo